les plus anciennes d'entre nous savent
que les lieux de d'échangisme où le
libre échangisme sont restés ouverts
durant tout le confinement de de très
nombreux de notre soleil
ils y avaient leurs habitudes dans des
mandats précédents
et je ne compte même pas les ministres
alors et alors me donne pas envie
d'arriver alors bruno heynckes est avec
nous vous êtes patron d'un club libertin
oui merci bruno ces langues puisque
bruno on le voit comme ça tu te dis
franchement ça peut être mon conseiller
financier mais bon non mais ça j'aime
bien mais pas trop du club libertin
l'hippocampe à sa mort dans le
val-de-marne et l'hippocampe promet
choisi ce nom assez sérieux dans sa 90 8
déjà et 23 ans saint palais de qobba on
a pris un animal de la mer avec mon
épouse ma défunte épouse parce qu'on
voulait quelque chose qui soit mieux mis
femmes et bonheur hippocampe exactement
bah oui on a un sauna hammam jacuzzi
donc tu connais
alors est déjà est ce que vous êtes
choqués par la sortie de jean lassalle
oui ou non bernard montiel non non c'est
rigolo il fait il nous fait une chanson
oui voilà il balance des noms comme ça
ça mange pas de pain brit-brit drôle
jean lassalle ça fait plusieurs fois qui
choque un peu toujours l'assemblée c'est
son style
tiffany non non pas du tout parce que si
ça avait été quelqu'un d'autre
oui mais lui on est habitué à ses
punchlines on est habitué à christ à sa
petite sortie foot donc pas quand ça m'a
pas choqué du tout laurence moi oui
parce que l'enceinte de l'assemblée
nationale d'avoir un gardien mais pour
moi c'est une teinte protégé où on parle
pas de ces histoires là et d'ailleurs
les politiques c'est leur vie privée
personnelle et on n'a pas en parler
n'importe où bah oui c'est pas parce
qu'on est aux politiques qu'on rentre au
couvent encore on a droit de vivre ça
doit pas être dit encore moins à
l'assemblée nationale oui moi non ça ne
m'a pas choqué du tout parce
qu'effectivement c'est jean lassalle
père fait pardon il enfonce des portes
ouvertes parce que c'est tellement
laclos notoriété publique
alors justement bruno avant d'avoir la
vie des autres est-ce que vous avez déjà
reçu des personnalités
oui dans votre établissement on a un
masque dans votre réseau
non non non à prendre il convient mais
je suis fermé depuis le 14 mars et
dernière fois le 28 novembre d'ouvrir il
y avait quoi tu devant moi j'ai voulu
mourir parce que moi je suis pas une
boîte de nuit fin je peins unique je
fais sonam à 3 heures jean bataillon
ranger pour me faire fermer de force un
petit peu de foot vous fait très peu de
musique la main
un chat on a des gens des gens connus
qui viennent aux idées des hommes
politiques des prénoms
est ce qu'il ya autour de la table qui
est allé chez vous oui c'est énorme
bruno je vais être franc je vais te fait
souhaite reprendre la tête je ne dirais
pas qui c'est alors est-ce que si on se
calme et bruno aubry n'est pas vraiment
une personne autour de la table
vous avez déjà vu de votre établissement
juste c'est une fille ou un garçon non
je peux pas répondre d'accord mais c'est
une fois les ménages et je répondrai pas
vous l'avez vu une fois je répondrai pas
sans rigoler non parce qu'il ya une
histoire de privé c'est à dire que le
libertin ja c'est un état d'esprit à
bien sûr et je pense que monsieur la
salière qui a fait cette remarque il
faut être honnête aujourd'hui c'est un
peu l'hypocrisie c'est très bien que les
hommes politiques comme les
présentateurs télé où les chants et la
balance et voulez vous avez les
présentateurs télé qui sont nus oui oui
je n'ai pas d'une femme tient à boucler
ça commence par ces jeunes et images
avaient vu un ouais c'est dans le bal de
marc donc free ça veut dire qu'ils se
déplacent là bas loin ce à côté tu crois
c'est pas la même qu'ici la loire ou
touche à tout âge à tous
la fée bruno donc vous avez déjà vu donc
des présentateurs télé les artistes
indés les chanteurs des acteurs s'est vu
confisquer les portables là bas alors
non il nous arrive une histoire je
voulais raconter c'était sous l'ère
sarkozy
monsieur sarkozy nous avons un homme qui
nous a laissés un portable à l'accueil
parce que des fois les parents laissent
les enfants à la maison et il nous
laisse les portables au bar pour qu'on
puisse s'y au cas où et combien de cas
les parents qui sont en train de faire
mon fils je me suis était très sympa une
loi lagarde et moi mon portable très
posé et puis un moment le téléphone a
sonné on a vu afficher sur le portable
au bar monsieur président sarkozy donc
on s'est dit tiens c'est important ça va
être important donc on a été chercher le
monsieur en plein ébats et on lui a dit
que le portable avait sonné et que l'on
pouvait pas dire ce qui était affiché
parce que halo et puis donc été
certainement quelques et après on l'a
reconnue donc voilà ouais était manquée
scanner doit politique oui adacore a pas
parce que l'appreil pour nicolas sarkozy
non mais il ya tout vous savez c'est
ouvert à tout le monde à partir des
nageurs le libertinage c'est une forme
voilà c'est un plaisir c'est un loisir
voilà serait alors pas sur une idée
malsain de libertinage est ce que est ce
que donc les comptes jean lassalle dit
les politiques ils vont souvent est-ce
qu'ils vont plus que les autres c'est
pareil c'est tout mais non c'est pareil
c'est un peu simple hypocrisie c'est un
peu comme l'histoire monsieur chalencon
avec les repas au restaurant privé la
corse est un petit peu d'hypocrisie il
ya toujours des soirées comme lieu
depuis le confinement et on aura
toujours même si c'est fermé il y en
aura toujours
quand ce sera ouvert on sait très bien
que quand environ il ya 3500 à 4000
paires soirées libertines en france oui
toutes les semaines sinon comment
séquence assez pour mener c'est pas pour
bruno
de lui bruno et bruno alors bon parce
que je voulais dire quelque chose quand
même parce qu'il resurgit rennais votre
émission avec la tunisie d'un
enterrement hier je suis un petit bisou
à un ami qui est décédé hier j'étais à
son tour gt gt ce matin encore en
auvergne je suis venu pour vous et à
l'oseraie chez je poursuis la sq il a 14
ans n'est pas son papa et hier j'ai ce
matin j'ai regardé l'intervention de
monsieur la salle mais j'ai regardé
aussi votre émission sur discothèque
je pense qu'aujourd'hui on a un
gouvernement qui n'a pas compris que un
commerce et un commerce
ils ne sont pas qui est un commerce plus
qu'un autre mais moins qu'un autre ça
aujourd'hui on parle des clubs libertins
parce que monsieur la salle a fait cette
intervention il faut savoir que j'ai
écrit plus de 45 ou courrier recommandé
premier ministre a rappelé que j'ai
jamais eu de réponse comme par hasard à
des députés et des sénateurs il y en a
certains qui m'ont répondu qu'ils
modifient fallait que je me taise
ah ben voilà mais je crois
qu'aujourd'hui on est en est une
hypocrisie totale je crois que tous les
commerces de mourir et 1 ap un passé
commun et ce après garde la différence
avec un restaurant italien sait que dans
un restaurant italien tu bouffes une
pizza qui lui tu bouffes aucune
différence très intéressé je trouve une
fois je suis allé une fois fallait quand
même que je vois ça ah oui c'était
génial
alou belle et riz doré ça sent mauvais
mais j'adorais un fusil exprès donc
[Rires]
chez valérie si leurs fins les
chandelles de bray non non non non
c'était au cap d'agde au cap d'agde à
vienne aussi beaucoup amusé au glamour
sefolosha l'adoré mais j'ai adoré même
réglementation que les discothèques
voilà donc c'est différent on a tout de
même parce que des gens ne savent pas
musique mais les gens font la musique et
même quelque part mais il ya de la
musique d'ambiance
il ya un bail à un sauna et un hammam et
un jacuzzi l'a400m et quatre coins
câlins mais je vais ouvrir de quoi
cadres et je vais ouvrir le 1er juillet
et le jeudi 1er juillet l'après midi on
joue le soir normal en club libertin
mais l'après-midi gphone journée portes
ouvertes est ouvert à tous les médias
tout le monde ceux qui veulent bosser
pour ce que c'est qu'un établissement
pour pas se faire une idée dans la tête
que c'est pas des bordels d'accord ce
sont les entreprises on prend il des
salariés il faut pas tout confondre
comme il a raison alors long ça y est ce
que vous êtes vous vous que c'est vous
qui êtes déjà les idées politiques n'ont
pas chômé politique ici sachez monsieur
vous êtes la seule la seule politique
ici est ce que vous êtes déjà le club du
herti mais sans rien faire comme je vous
ai expliqué tout à l'heure que la vie
privée des politiques devaient rester
privée si je vous répondais je casserai
tout mon argumentaire non mais je reste
sur ma position du toulon n'est pas
l'assemblée nationale est soit déjà les
bains pour regarder vous savez parfois
on reste devant la vitrine on achèterait
dans un magasin répondrai pas insérée
pour qui elle ne répond pas et prier jeu
plus posé là même qui aurait pour effet
déjà les cm2 la vigueur à l'été porte
parole directe namigata les calades
porter la parole ici si je répondais
fout tout en l'air tout ce que j'ai
expliqué de télé une cohérence on s'en
fout c'est pas la première fois que dans
cette émission va tout est à faire
non c'est que vous non à moins d'y
apposer n + paix fois un ouais c'est
vrai mais justement les présidents et
les journalistes quand vous propose dans
ces endroits de monsieur cissé sur son
disque quand les politiques et les
journalistes quand ils nous proposent de
les accompagner ils sont totalement
désinhibé mais vous ils ont ils ont
jamais peur d'être surpris d'être non je
vous m'avez j'étais surpris en 88/89 les
premiers qui venait cette année non
maintenant
non maintenant je suis pas surpris que
celle ci ait beaucoup d'hypocrisie et
non mais c'est vrai parce que mes
enfants adorent qu en vérité ça marche
je vous dis franchement non c'est vrai
nom voilà que ce soit chez ou ailleurs
et je serais quand même je me dirai pas
mené à la journée oui alors là j'ai
[Applaudissements]
quand même que la journée portes
ouvertes c'est juste uniquement pour les
gens voyez comment est un établissement
liberté mais c'est pas du tout outre des
cuisines et des hypocrisies autour de ça
puisque capcom a dit jean lassalle
voilà c'est que tout le monde est là et
que voilà les scellés chacun fait ce
qu'il veut de son cul enfin je suis
désolé c'est la vie pris le problème
c'est qu'on en fait tout un tapage va au
lieu de parler de ça on vient de parler
de la crise sociale qui va bientôt
tomber sur berges de la têt et parler
aussi des commerces qui vont ouvrir en
espérant qu'on referont fine pas au mois
de septembre choix que la gestion de
cette crise était très mal fait parler
politique et aujourd'hui on en paye les
pots cassés parce que les aides sociales
certains en profitent d'autant profite
pas est ce que est ce que vous avez une
autre anecdote avec une personne voilà
connus ou personnes connues oui j'ai une
anecdote qui est assez bizarre c'est que
une fois nous avons eu un couple qui est
venu très gentil très simple je n'avais
pas reconnu au départ la dame et c'est
au bout d'un moment j'entends une jeune
femme arrivée en criant hurlant et avec
son son homme qui me dit c'est intel qui
là c'est un tel que là c'est pas
possible
il m'a baisé je peux plus je peux futé
[Applaudissements]
et donc est donc à la fin cette personne
et je n'ai pas reconnu mon cher pas que
c'était une personne aussi connu que ça
et je lui ai dit vous savez vous avez
perturber un petit couple qui est partie
paniqué parce que hélas la dame a dit si
on peut plus baisers où on veut en
montrant sa touche pas mon transfert je
suis désolé j'aimerais qu'on ne vit plus
vous savez j'ai plus de 300 appels par
jour quand même pour ouvrir non ça
change énormément de gens qui veulent
venir à la salle et dans les journées
sont chaudes gilles verdez est-ce que
vous dépendez bien d'aller la
législation sur les clubs de sport et
donc est ce que ça vous permet de
rouvrir avant de vous on m'a dit que
vous ouvriez le 19 justement non
j'entends j'entends aboyer à gorée le
1er juillet moi je vous le 1er juillet a
totalement toute façon il faut qu on
nous prévient que si c'est pour entrer
35 % de la clientèle chez moi très
important je trouve pas les 2000 un jeu
attention si vous rentrez tout votre
attention néophytes parce que je vous ai
jamais entendu aux attentes des invités
de four 12
je voulais revenir avec plaisir mais
parce que puisque on n'arrête pas de
dire qu'il faut qu' il y compris quand
on va faire des courses quand on va
fermer boutique etc qui est de la
distanciation social que ce bon là c'est
moi c'est pas sûr après ça vous le savez
le problème c'est que j'étais passé sur
une autre chaîne j'aurais pas laquelle
on a passé d'enquêté exclusive
on a mûri je le vire est choquée pas par
le bas ouais d'accord le sida ok mais le
virus jusqu'à preuve du contraire il va
pas rentrer dans une château en fait
c'était vous savez pas que c'était vous
qui aviez dit ça j'avais trouvé ça
totalement absurde mais vous rendez
compte
non mais on peut très bien avoir la ja
pas de gestes barrières du tout chez
vous il y en a plus du tout c'est comme
ça qu'on peut avoir le virus voulait me
dire que fait excuser moi pouvait pas
reprendre vos mots mais évidemment que
c'est à cet endroit précis qu'il n'ya
pas du tout de gestes barrières et bien
au delà et vous courir dans le métro il
y en a des gestes barrières mais moi je
parlerais attendez vous prenez une femme
en direct vous avez pas besoin
oui bah là bien là où vous avez pardon
mais vous dites qu'ils font ce qu'ils
veulent de leur cul mais pardonnez moi
moi je me souviens d'une histoire dans
les années 90 mon nom était au quai
d'orsay non non où on cherchait un
ministre parce qu'il y avait un état
d'urgence cette nuit là oui et on l'a
jamais trouvé
non et je vous assure de chocolat comme
ça je voudrais juste répondre à moi non
partisane y répondre quand j'ai mis ça
dans le reportage c'est fait pour donner
une image de le fait qu' on ferme tous
les commerces sont fermés personnes
c'était pour montrer l'absurdité de ce
gouvernement qui dit blanc dit noir un
jour on manque les masques en fait pas
de masque on nous la moitié des
commerces ont fait voilà c'est un peu la
pagaille quoi aujourd'hui on est on est
complètement dans cette actualité là
passe et surtout tu prends un live toi
rien contre le wat a choisi un club il
ya un groupe qui va tourner un clip dans
une semaine au club
ils ont loué le club pour faire un
tournage mais un clip vidéo d'accord
battre à vos côtés c'est une bonne
nouvelle
ou être deux ou tout seul pour rentrer
chez vous oui c'est vrai peut être seul
non c'est les couples switchés
alors j'ai fait les soirées gay avant le
combine mais là pour reprendre faire
d'abord des soirées mixte à raison de
cinq soirées couple uniquement en couple
j'adore rose était jeune j'ai pu y aller
oui
après quand je suis devenu connu tout du
tout mais en revanche une sangle a dit
avoir été avec ma députée pour
l'inauguration d'un sauna au mans pour à
l'occasion de la gay pride
exact et oui là donc il y est allé lui
non au mans je sais de quelques ses
mains au monde d'accord l'arrière et la
quéquette cas merci de nous avoir
éclairé
non il ya plus de cash que je retiens de
bruno senna dit calme qui avait une
personne est saisie celle qui annonce
pas lui qui est non qui l'a déjà vu dans
son club et j'ai envie c'est lui la
position tandis que c'est moi j'ai ma
petite idée
ouais c'est pernikoff que j'ai pas
nicolas chercher même sous la torture
ah oui bah très bon bateau retour à
l'école j'avais des mercis coup non
reste à voir et avec son patron
merci d'avoir été là alors que les
téléspectateurs cette image s'il vous
plaît oui à 22%
voilà mon ressenti comme je suis pas du
tout évoqué jeu qu'avec vous isabelle là
dessus